[Music]
one more time the cares act didn't care
um it's an oxymoron
it had so many unintended consequences
and so such poor
implementation but when you hear ronald
reagan used to say it
some of the scariest words on the planet
is i'm from the government and i'm here
to help
right uh if that doesn't scare your
socks off nothing will
because they're gonna screw up christmas
i mean they're unbelievable it's the
island of misfit toys up there
so uh the cares act of course was
supposed to stop
student loan interest and collection of
student loan payments until september to
give
people a break due to coronavirus
suppression and economic shutdowns and
all that kind of stuff
and it has not worked out that way it
hasn't worked out
so they've stopped interest dave but
they're still reporting to the credit
reporting agencies
uh that people are delinquent now this
is not every single company but a lot of
the companies out there
are still reporting negative and on top
of that dave they're still
pulling money from their checks from
their bank accounts
so if you had a deal set up where you
were having your your account drafted
because you were in default
they didn't stop that nope nope they
were supposed to stop that and if you
didn't pay
because you weren't supposed to pay
under cares act there's a chance
that a reasonably good chance that
you're being reported as
not as being delinquent yes you're
getting negative dings
on your credit bureau report so if you
have a federal student loan
check your credit yeah and call your
loan provider and
confirm that you're in good standing so
you don't get penalized
and all of this might lead you to go
ahead and get with splash financial and
go ahead and get refinanced now
yeah this advertiser that we've got does
a great job but again you don't need to
do that
if you're not if you don't have a
problem and unless you can get a cheaper
interest rate but there's no closing
costs on this
and they can run the refinance of splash
financial and you know we're big
proponents of these guys they're one of
our advertisers and there's a reason we
put them on the air
was this um yeah this is episode number
bajillion of why you cannot trust the
government
you can't trust the government dave and
we saw that when it came to the student
loan forgiveness
you know i did a deep sty a d deep dive
and deep study into that
but the government failed that only one
they only approved one percent of the
people to forgive
but lured all them into this particular
field or go out to this particular
school or do this particular career
and will forgive but only one percent
were forgiven and so
of course when this came and i was like
something's going to happen well i mean
the problem is
you that you they put in place a law
and then expected people who are
incompetent to become competent
right when you look navient up in the
greek it means incompetent
i mean you're just not dealing with
intelligent life when you call over
there yeah
it's like people's parents are cousins
or something it's unbelievable
yeah so uh you know you just if you
assume
that a group of people who have
misbehaved and have
didn't give a rip and uh you know
trash your credit were gonna stop doing
that because of the cares act
that would have been a wrong assumption
absolutely and you know what dave here's
why i like splash financial if you can
refi uh their lowest interest rate right
now is right around 3.25 so the national
average is right around four or four and
a half
um and so and up to about six six and a
half so
um if if that guy donovan was six and a
half so you think
you think he could get what uh three
it's three and a quarter oh really three
and a quarter at splash financial that's
their lowest
so of course you know they assuming
everything lines up perfect exactly
exactly so it's like if you can if it
does save you money splash financial is
a great route
yeah 170 grand three percent savings is
significant
yes sir yes there it is even over two
years absolutely
it doesn't get him out of debt what gets
him out of debt is the 100k a year going
towards it but
the a little bit of savings on the
interest and no closing costs that's
known as a no-brainer
folks once again what happens at your
house is more important than what
happens in the white house
it has more to do with whether you
become successful in this life
absolutely i have never met a
multi-millionaire who said you know it's
all because of washington
never once this is the dave ramsey show